So now I really went to art school. I
thank Amy for the Greece drawing. So what does it
take to make a network like this work? So
let's suppose we wanted to send a message from Rhodes
to Sparta, and we have many points along the
way where we can send smoke signals. So we'd start
by sending a smoke signal from Rhodes. This would be
visible from a few other points. And to reach Sparta,
the one at Naxos would need to resend it,
would need to also submit it as smoke signal
that would be visible at some other points. The
one at Melos would need to see it and
resend it. And maybe that's already visible at Sparta.
So we need several different things in order to
make a network like this work. The first thing
we need is a way to encode messages. We need
to be able to convert the message that we want
to send, say it's a message that says the Trojans are
arriving. We needed to be able to send that message and
encode that in a smoke signal. We need a way to
do routing. We need to figure out where the message should
go. If we want to send it to Sparta, we need to
know that it should be forwarded by these nodes. The node
that sees it from Miletus does not need to resend it.
Probably the way the ancient Greek network worked, all the
nodes resent every message. They didn't have a way to do
routing selectively. But that's very wasteful. What we'd like is
a way to only send the message to the destination it
goes to. For the kinds of messages the ancient Greeks
were sending that says things like the enemy's arriving, well, it
was okay. You wanted to send it everywhere, that's called
flooding the net. But if we want to send messages just
between two points, we've got to know which nodes should
resend the message or which direction to send it in. And
the final thing we need to worry about is, we need
to decide who gets to use the network. So it might
be that there are more than one enemy arriving at once
or maybe, the enemy is arriving, it might be at the
same time. Achilles, say Achilles is in Melos, and he wants
to send a message back to Medea in Delphi. So maybe
Achilles wants to send a message that would go like this at
the same time as the army needing to send this important message
that's saying the Trojans are arriving. So we need to figure out
who gets to use the network and what they get to send.
So, these are all things the ancient Greek network would have had
to deal with if it was sophisticated enough to worry about them.
If it was just sending the message that says the troops are
arriving, well, that's one smoke signal and it didn't necessarily need that.
All of these are the same things that we need to
worry about if we want to send messages on the internet. So
these are the things that we need to make any network.
We need some way to take the messages that we want to
send and encode them in a way that they can be
transmitted, and interpret them when they get to that other end. For
the Greeks, the message was something like, Agamemnon is arriving, get the
ships to a safe place. And they needed to encode that in
a smoke signal. We need a way to route messages.
We need a way for the receiver of this smoke
signal to know the next place to send it. And
for the Ancient Greek network, since smoke signals are not directional,
they just go up in the air, there wasn't much
to do here. Everyone could see the message and they
wanted to send the message everywhere. If we want to send
messages just between two points, this becomes a much tougher problem.
We need rules for deciding who gets to use resources.
If there are two messages that want to go through the
same place, well, only one of those can be sent at
a time. We need some way to decide when. For the
Greeks, well, I don't know what their rules were, but let's
assume their rule was, if you're a general, your message has
priority. We needed all these same things for the Internet. Before
we talk about how they are done on the Internet, I
am going to introduce the two main ways that we measure networks.